nicolas dupont aignan bonjour bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
dans la matinale de rtl france alors on
va parler situation sanitaire avec les
restrictions de déplacements et les
attestations en journée qui prendront
fin le 3 mai on parle encore d'un
plateau un pic peut-être pas encore
atteint d'ailleurs cette levée
progressive est ce que c'est le bon
tempo pour vous écouter tout ce qui va
vers une levée de ces mesures stupide
qui ne servent à rien et je pense
notamment au couvre-feu est à la
restriction des 10 km sera positif parce
que on peut pas continuer comme ça avec
des mesures vraiment inutile je pense au
couvre feu le 19 heures qui n'a aucun
sens puisque les gens s'entassent dans
les métros dans les airs vers et que
dans la plupart des pays
même quand ya un couvre-feu il est à 21h
ou 22h 20h mais vraiment si on pouvait
arrêter avec ces mesures symboliques qui
ne sert à rien ce serait positif des
mesures symboliques qui est certes un
rien et pourtant il ya encore des
contaminations assez importante
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on fait selon
vous mais oui justement il ya des
contaminations importante parce que ces
mesures sont des mesures d'affichage
moyen-âgeuse si on veut éviter les
contaminations faut par exemple est
beaucoup plus attentifs dans les
transports on voit des gens serrés comme
des sardines dans des rames de métro qui
ont souvent des masques en tissu par
exemple je demande depuis des mois que
pour les personnes fragiles car encore
une fois tous les français ne sont pas
les dix armes égales face au virus eh
bien je demande que le gouvernement
offre des masques ffp2 très protecteur
une personne âgée ou une personne avec
comorbidités qui est obligé de prendre
le métro
il faut qu'elles soient bien protégés
voilà une mesure qui n'a rien à voir
avec le couvre-feu ou avec des
restrictions mais qui permet de protéger
les personnes depuis le début de cette
crise je dis qu'il faut protéger les
personnes plutôt que d'interdire de
manière systématique des choses je
pourrais prendre aussi l'exemple des
soins précoces toujours un retard
incroyable les purificateurs d'air dans
les écoles et dans les lieux publics et
dans les bureaux toujours pas fait
en un mot ce qui est un supporter les
lits d'hospitalisation qui manque bien
sûr et les lits pérenne qui ne sont pas
augmentés
donc ce qui ne va pas dans cette crise
depuis des mois mais je le dis depuis
des mois dans le désert si je puis dire
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas compris que les
mesures moyen-âgeuse était inutile qu'il
fallait au contraire cibler les
protections sur les personnes fragile
c'est tout l'enjeu d'une politique
intelligente de lutte contre la copie d
qui marchent dans certains pays et pas
chez nous justement à propos de la
question de cibler l'exécutif ca s'est
exprimé sur sa stratégie à suivre
écouter gabriel attal son porte parole
la territorialisation est évidemment une
option qui est aujourd'hui sur la table
dans l'organisation et la réouverture
progressive
il n'y a pas de décision prise sur le
sujet mais c'est une option sur la table
parmi d'autres une bonne option la
territorialisation selon vous justement
pour laisser un peu plus libre ce qui
serait moins touchées oui mais enfin
c'est une bande d'amateurs incroyable je
sais pas si vous réalisez le ridicule et
la tragédie de la situation en france
un porte parole du gouvernement qui nous
dit que des options sur la table
en fait le problème de fond de gestion
de cette crise c'est qu'il ya un homme
sol dans un conseil de défense sans
compte rendu public qui décide on ne
sait pas comment un conseil scientifique
complètement nul qui s'est trompé
énormément et qui ne publie pas ses
comptes rendus un retard systématique
sur toutes les innovations
technologiques
ça commence est insupportable
représentants de l'opposition selon vous
il devrait participer à il pourrait
participer à ces à ses conseils
justement sur la situation sanitaire
il faudrait déjà rouvrir le parlement
c'est donald trump ou poutine avait
supprimé les droits du parlement depuis
mars
mais tous les journalistes de france
serait surexcités à dire que c'est une
la fin la démocratie et je vous signale
que depuis mars 2020 depuis mars 2020 on
le parlement ne décide plus rien en
matière sanitaire des ordonnances ont
pris d'emblée tous les domaines des
droits du travail
il n'ya plus de démocratie dans notre
pays
on n'a pas le droit de le dire donc il
n'ya pas de démocratie
donc c'est même pas la question
d'associer les membres de l'opposition
au conseil de défense c'est de rétablir
le parlement dans ses droits qu'ils
votent les mesures même pendant la
guerre de 14-18 heureusement qu'ils
avaient à parlement parce que c'est
comme ça qu'est manceau a pu virer les
généraux incompétents qui avait envoyé
au massacre des dizaines de milliers de
français sur les champs de bataille et
qui a pu gagner la guerre donc il n'ya
même pas de débat
y a rien c'est le silence radio mais
notre pays est en train de très mal
tourner donc moi j'alerte j'ai fait des
propositions très concrètes très
précises ni déni de la maladie il ya une
vraie épidémie ni affolement pour qu'on
reprenne l'offensive mais pourquoi
certains pays comme le maroc
certains pays comme la slovaquie
certains je parle pas des pays d'asie y
arrive et pas nous alors c'est
incroyable justement alors le le
gouvernement le chef de l'état s'est
exprimé à propos de la stratégie
vaccinale le gouvernement qui peine à
convaincre un les français à aller se
faire vacciner écouter le chef de l'état
des difficultés pour convaincre malgré
tous nos citoyens sur la phrase est née
caf qui est une problématique à laquelle
là on doit collectivement réfléchir en
termes de communication et de capacité à
convaincre et justement sur la table en
termes de communication selon le canard
enchaîné une célèbre chanteuse
pourrait-elle choisies pour montrer
l'exemple devant les caméras est-ce que
tout est beau finalement pour promouvoir
le vaccin mais écoutez il ya des
beaucoup de pays qui ont interdit le
vaccin est rasé n'est qu'à et il est le
président de la république
je pense que ce vaccin c'est fini pour
la france et le président de la
république
voilà nous parle il faut communiquer il
faut convaincre on dirait un petit
garçon avec son jouet qui n'est pas
content mais il ya un moment il faut
être sérieux mais il ya plus aucune
crédibilité les français n'ont plus
confiance dans ce gouvernement
puisque monsieur vers ans a menti
systématiquement la confiance dans des
périodes difficiles est un élément clé
la confiance vient de la vérité et la
vérité vient dans la transparence
y a pas de transparence vous le savez
très bien donc moi ce que je dis depuis
le départ c'est qu'on luttera contre
cette épidémie par une pas l'aide
solution l'ivermectine qui marchent en
slovaquie il ya une chute brutale depuis
qu'ils l'ont employé cet anti
parasitaire qui tint soins précoces
extraordinaire qui est mille fois mieux
que le doliprane
mais l'assurance maladie continue à dire
aux gens qui sont positifs
rentrez chez vous prenez du doliprane
heureusement qu'il ya l'association les
sens les prescrire heureusement tu es
des médecins dévoués dans le pays qui
n'écoutent pas l'assurance maladie ni le
gouvernement
donc moi ce que je demande la vitamine d
la vitamine d sais pas c'est simple vous
savez que le dosage de vitamine d pour
qu'on sache combien on a de vitamine d
dans le corps n'est toujours pas
remboursé par la sécurité sociale
il est vital que notamment les personnes
fragiles face à un examen de sang pour
savoir s'ils ont le bon dosage de
vitamine t si on a le bon dosage
on renforce l'immunité de la personne de
80% ça veut dire 80 % de moins de
risques d'attraper la co vide
donc j'aimerais aussi qu'on fasse des
statistiques sur les profils des gens en
réanimation
parce que normalement on me dit je veux
vérifier que les personnes qui souffrent
de surpoids seraient beaucoup plus en
danger et là il ya toute une
organisation alimentaire affaires dans
le pays car vous savez que l'obésité a
explosé en france mais ça veut dire
s'attaquer à certaines industries
alimentaires donc ce que je veux dire
c'est que ces prises comment on crise
elle révèle un tout vous comprenez on
vous en parlait justement de la question
alimentaire
hier le ministre de l'intrus de la
culture de l'agriculture pardon il est
revenu sur une proposition d'un
convention pour le climat emmanuel
macron avait prévu un chèque
alimentaires notamment pour les
étudiants pour un accès à une nourriture
équilibrée nourriture locale écouter
julien de normandie à propos d'un chèque
de 50 euros
on se rend compte qu'aujourd'hui c'est
probablement cette somme qui vous permet
d'avoir accès sur un panier alimentaire
moyens notamment pour les étudiants à ce
coup de pouce qui permet d'avoir accès à
ses produits frais alors ce un chèque de
50 euros par mois pour manger équilibré
pour manger local est ce que ça un bon
coup de pouce pour les jeunes ce que ça
suffit 50e l'idée l'idée peut être
intelligente mais je vois pas comment
elle va s'appliquer
je vois pas comment va la mettre en
oeuvre donc moi je l'idée peut être
intéressant
quand et pour soutenir nos producteurs
locaux mais c'est à mon avis une usine à
gaz bureaucratique ce que j'avais
proposé beaucoup plus à mon avis c'est
le problème des étudiants aujourd'hui
quel est il c'est que les petits boulots
ont disparu voilà et que nos étudiants
sont dans la misère
donc qu'est ce qu'il faut pour relancer
l'économie on n'y est point avec des
mesures de précaution bien sûr mais on
pourrait ouvrir des restaurants à madrid
et restaurants sont ouverts
il n'y a pas de risque si on se protège
et qu'on à l'intelligent donc d'abord
faut relancer l'activité et puis
deuxième point j'ai proposé des travaux
d'utilité collective ce que j'appelle
travail universel c'est à dire 200 mille
contrats pour les jeunes qui auraient
une tâche à mi temps ou la carte de
temps dans une collectivité pour leur
permettre de retrouver le petit boulot
privé qu'il n'avait pas qu'ils ont perdu
parce que c'est ça le problème
aujourd'hui des jeunes c'est cette
misère étudiante mais il faut traiter la
cause
moi j'aime bien qu'on distribue un
chèque pour faire bien devant la télé le
temps qu'il arrive et puis qu'est-ce que
comment les jeunes vont savoir l'on va
leur demander une autorisation encore à
faire la paperasse savoir où est ce
qu'ils dépensent en face et le retour
c'est je vois pas comment on va réaliser
ça donc je préférerais qu'il y ait des
petits boulots pour les jeunes je
préférais aussi qu'on a nos agriculteurs
par des prix garantis des productions ce
qui se passait avant et qu'on n'applique
la loyale hymne qui n'est pas appliquée
par la grande distribution
ce serait beaucoup plus intelligent que
ces mesures en fait on a un gouvernement
je sais pas si vous le ressentez mais
moi je le ressens comme ça qu'ils
courent après les événements et qui
invente des que la communication on a vu
président et ses dix mille policiers et
il y en a eu mille de moins depuis 2017
et il répète partout qu'un à dix mille
de plus voilà bon mais plus un français
de croissance alors c'est terrible
vous parlez de la question des policiers
effectivement la question de la sécurité
très présente
c'est en ce début de semaine le verdict
dans la sphère des policiers attaqués à
viry châtillon qui n'en finit pas lui
aussi de faire parler de lui gérald
darmanin va recevoir les policiers
victimes fera samedi l'une des avocats
des acquittés qui ont passé quatre ans
en prison le rappelle a demandé au garde
des sceaux de recevoir s'est acquitté
voyez la réponse d'eric dupond-moretti
recevoir les a quittés sur cette affaire
en particulier mais sur d'autres
également
ce sera de toute façon interpréter et
mal
alors du coup comment est-ce que vous
interprétez ce refus d'eric
dupond-moretti de recevoir les a quittés
ce qu'il a raison attardez la question
c'est pas de recevoir les gens et entre
nous les les policiers victimes se passe
ils sont heureux d'être supprimée nice
l'intérieur mais il serait heureux
qu'ils aient une justice en france
qu'est une police respecté et que quand
on veut tuer quelqu'un le brûlé vif dans
sa voiture brûlée vive dans sa voiture
et le policier je vous signale qu'il a
passé des semaines dans un coma
artificiel et qu'il a failli mourir il a
des séquelles aujourd'hui il aimerait
surtout qu'on soit pas condamné entre 6
et 18 ans parce que ça veut dire à la
fin de trois à neuf ans de prison
et c'est le seul pays au monde où vous
pouvez vous à gré à gré c'est vouloir
tuer un policier et vous en tirer sans
perpétuité ou 130 ans de prison et donc
faut pas s'étonner après que dans nos
banlieues
les policiers soient insulter agresser
et fluide donc c'est une république mais
kéké qu'elle couchait qui est sous terre
il fonctionne il faut que nos bleus
il faut plus de bleu dans les rues de
france aujourd'hui comme l'a dit hier
emmanuel macron mais cette expression
montre qu'il n'a rien compris
parce que aujourd'hui les bleus comme il
dit ils peuvent plus rentrer dans
beaucoup de quartiers il ya une guerre
donc il faut surtout que la justice soit
rendue au nom du peuple français il faut
voter de nouvelles lois j'ai proposé
depuis des années une peine plancher
pour les agressions de policiers puisque
les magistrats font pas le boulot
puisque les magistrats estime que oncle
adressé un policier sans avoir livré à
un véritable conséquence dans le pays
on ne compte pas d'ailleurs les peines
avec sursis quand il ya des insultes etc
il faut absolument changer de cap pénal
et pour moi je proposerai dans le cadre
de ma candidature la présidentielle que
ce soit adoptée par référendum en début
de mandat les magistrats ne font pas
grève contre le peuple
parce qu'à un moment ça suffit
aujourd'hui la réalité c'est que des
bandes dans tout le pays
agressent nos policiers etc on ne réagit
pas il faut comprendre la colère des
policiers qui vivent un enfer au
quotidien
peut-être un dernier mot sur cette autre
des six
du gouvernement la création d'un poste
de préfet délégué à l'immigration auprès
du préfet de police de paris avec pour
mission coordonner la gestion des flux
migratoires en ile de france il est il
est nécessaire ce nouveau poste cette
création de poste
non mais ça va faire un poste de plus
pour la nomenklatura mafa c'est ridicule
mais ce mais sait on touche le fond
qu'est ce qui compte c'est de contrôler
nos frontières c'est de créer des
centres de rétention pour les demandeurs
d'asile à nos frontières pour que quand
on refuse la demande d'asile va et
s'évapore pas dans la nature et on le
renvoie dans son pays
c'est de supprimer le droit du sol c'est
de suspendre le regroupement familial
c'est d'expulser les délinquants
étrangers au terme de leur peine est ce
que font tous les pays adultes voilà
donc on va créer un nouveau préfet qu'il
va faire encore des rapports et pendant
ce temps là la situation est désastreuse
je vous rappelle que plus de 250 mille
personnes sont rentrées de manière
légale et qui a au moins cent cinquante
mille demandeurs native 400 milles
vous imaginez ce que ça représente
chaque année et qu'on gère rien alors on
va mettre un préfet chargé de réguler
les flux mais je ne sais pas où va notre
pays et je pense que les français leur
centre et c'est pourquoi au-delà des
critiques parce que on a touché le fond
il faut absolument proposer aux français
des mesures simples qui existe dans
d'autres pays moi tout mon projet existe
ailleurs
c'est à dire qu'il a été mis en oeuvre
ici ou là et on peut redresser le pays
la seule chose que je veux dire c'est
qu'il faut d'urgence une alternance
politique
il faut que les français regardent des
projets des uns des autres c'est
important on est à moins d'un an de la
présidentielle
et vous avez vu comme le débat est
occultée on ne parle que du coc vide
mais il va y avoir un choix majeur et
emmanuel macron est en train d'organiser
sa réélection en insufflant la paix la
surveillance merci pas acceptable
merci beaucoup nicolas dupont aignan
d'avoir accepté notre invitation à
matinale de rtl france je le rappelle
vous êtes président de debout la france